(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This is the Lord
Howe Island stick insect,
and this species did the impossible,
they came back from extinction.
The Lord Howe Island stick insect
is the largest flightless stick insect,
and can grow up to four inches in length.
That's almost the length
of an adult human's hand.
It is affectionately
nicknamed the tree lobster,
the land lobster, and
even the walking sausage.
Lord Howe Island stick insects
were once so common on Lord Howe Island
that they were used as bait by fishermen.
Then a British supply ship
crashed on the island in 1918,
accidentally introducing
rats who ate the insects.
By 1960, they were declared extinct.
Then in 2001, Australian
scientists discovered
a tiny population hidden on a
small volcanic island nearby.
Thanks to a breeding
program at Melbourne Zoo,
they have been able to save
and repopulate this species.
This is the Lord Howe Island stick insect.
(upbeat music)
(tone sounds)